greetings everyone this is rob sanders
with simply learn thank you for joining
and today we're going to cover digital
marketing interview questions and
answers so thanks for joining again and
here's how it's gonna work so we broke
out a few questions and answers uh in
different categories a lot of you are
going to be interviewing for some jobs
out there and some of the jobs may be an
seo manager
or search engine marketing manager or
email marketing manager or content
marketing manager or social media
manager so we broke up those questions
into those areas and so that's what
we're going to do we're going to start
with seo we're going to go through some
questions and i'm going to explain the
answers to those questions so if you
have any questions to these questions or
answers feel free to just comment right
below this video and we'll get back to
you as soon as possible so let's get
started we're going to start with seo
search engine optimization we're going
to go through a series of questions and
i'm going to answer those questions for
you okay so the first question that you
might be asking an interview is
differentiate between do follows and no
follows okay so if you take in or listen
to my seo courses on youtube for seo we
we talked a lot about do follows and
nofollows and and simply put i mean do
follows are just signals to the search
engines to follow the link so there's a
link on site a pointing to site b
we're gonna basically tell google bing
and some of these other search engines
hey go ahead and follow that link now i
know file is just the opposite so no
follow link doesn't allow the search
engine crawlers to follow it so if we
have a link on our site
site a pointing to
site b we can put a nofollow tag in
there and what that's going to do it's
going to signal to the crawlers hey
don't follow this link so
in the end if the crawlers don't follow
the link then there's not going to be
any link juice passed and so google is
not going to give you credit or give
that site credit for having a link
pointing to it or pointing to another
site or from another site and so it's
all about linking so we can control if
there's links on our site whether we
want the crawlers to recognize those or
not simply with no follow text so just a
reminder link jews is the reputation of
equity passed from one website to
another so if you have a link on another
website and that website is of high
quality meaning their page authority
their domain authority is high they have
a lot of content you know they're not
spammy they're really rich and they're
relevant then you may want to make sure
that the link pointing from that site to
your site is a nofollow so that way that
google can recognize the link from that
site to your site and basically that
reputation is gonna be passed on to you
okay so that's a do follow versus a
nofollow and why would we do a no follow
well
it depends it really depends a lot of
social media platforms like facebook
have no follows if you have a lot of
content you may not want to be pushing
out a lot of do follows it could
actually look bad from an external
linking standpoint and so a lot of sites
are really particular about who they
want to pass link juice onto and give
credit for the link so it's a business
decision at the end of the day there's
really no hard fast rule here except
from an seo perspective if i have a site
and i have a lot of external links
pointing outward to other sites i'm
going to be particular about who i allow
the search engines to follow and what
links i allow not to follow so here's an
example of what they look like so do
follow is simply just the href notice
the nofollow has the the tag appended to
it the href tag with a nofollow so if
the search engine's crawling your site
and they see that nofollow there they're
not going to follow that link and vice
versa if there's a link on another site
pointing to yours and there's a no
follow there you're not going to get
credit the search engines aren't going
to pick up that link okay so question
two what is 301 redirect and how is it
different from a 302 redirect so
301 redirects tell users and the search
engine specifically that an original
page has been moved and this is the
keyword here permanently so permanently
moved we're going to explain that in a
minute so it's just moved from one page
to another and so if we
don't have a page anymore but we have a
new page let's just say you built a new
website with new urls you wanna make
sure the old page is pointing to the new
page with a 301 redirect so if a 301
redirect is permanent then a 302 is
temporary so we want the search engines
to
recognize that we have 301 permanent
redirects in place why because if we
have temporary then it might alert
google to
not keep that page in its search engine
rankings because it's temporary so why
would google want to keep a temporary
page or even a page that is pointing to
another page on a temporary basis so
they
may remove both pages from its index
okay but if we have something permanent
in place google may say okay this page
is permanently linking to another page
or redirecting to another page therefore
it's stable it's permanent we're going
to keep that new page in the index and
eventually remove the old page so really
something permanent is more stable in
the eyes of the search engine something
temporary
may not be as stable in the eyes of say
google and if they don't see it as
stable then they may remove both pages
from the index okay so the idea is we
want to be found in google search index
and we get it sometimes pages go away
for a variety of reasons and if it does
go away just make sure you have a new
page for it and that new page is a 301
permanent redirect okay so question
three why are backlinks important in seo
well we kind of
hinted on that a bit with the nofollow
because if we have a link from another
website pointing to ours and that link
from that other website is really
relevant and and it has a high page and
domain authority then it's going to
benefit us and so backlinks are
important because if we have backlinks
from quite quality sites it's going to
improve the credibility of our site
especially if it's a do follow tag so
the search engines are gonna recognize
the relationship between the site that
has a link pointing to us okay so it's
just gonna build our credibility it's
gonna increase increase our domain
authority and then the net effect of
that is if we're credible and we have
high domain authority then that's going
to increase the rankings of our pages
and when the pages increase in ranking
then we're going to get more of a lion's
share of the traffic for certain
keywords that our pages are found for
and if our pages are found and getting
traffic then because we have increased
rankings we're likely going to have
increased traffic and then it's just a
snowball effect so more traffic leads to
more engagement and conversions so
the whole idea for seo is remember you
have an on-page strategy and an off-page
strategy building external links is part
of an off-page seo strategy and we want
to make sure that you know we are
relevant in the form of a link or in the
form of content on other high quality
sites being on a high quality site only
benefits us because again increases our
domain authority google sees this is
more relevant therefore pages are going
to benefit by ranking higher and
therefore when we rank higher we get
more traffic so it's a snowball effect
so having backlinks is important because
it snowballs all the way through to
conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on youtube
this is a great question really great
question given the importance of videos
especially with seo because videos are
found youtube in itself is a search
engine so if we have a video how are we
going to get it to rank on youtube well
first things first you never want to put
a video out there and want it to rank if
it's not engaging or informative so
make sure you go ahead and follow the
best practices of having engaging in
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing the video are
you want to choose a title that has high
search volume and low difficulty just as
you would keyword for example for web
page you want to choose a title with a
keyword in it that has high volume and
low difficulty i.e low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know what you want to choose a title
that's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high volume you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake of the title they're going to want
to probably get a sneak peek via the
description of what it is so again you
want to optimize that description but
make sure the description is is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on twitter facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really short and to
the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant that's going
to grab somebody's attention and then
again we set it similar to the video
tags we want to use relevant hashtags
again just as you would with twitter and
facebook go ahead and throw some
hashtags in there that people could see
because people search via hashtagging
and then this goes about saying you did
all the work created a really great
video it's engaging it's informative you
optimized it feel free to promote your
video on other social media platforms
okay don't just stick with youtube per
se
so the benefit here is if you post it on
facebook or linkedin or whatever
platform of your choice and it gets
engagement people click on the link go
to youtube they're gonna like it and
then other people are gonna see that
engagement they're gonna see how many
people liked it or how many subscribers
you have so
promote your videos to help you with the
ranking of the video on youtube so that
does play into it so go ahead and
promote it so other people can watch it
like it comment etc and that's going to
engage other people to want to do the
same so what is mobile first indexing
this is a really important and timely
question mobile first indexing means
google's just using mobile friendly
content for indexing and ranking
websites so in other words google
for example has two bots they have the
traditional desktop bot and they have a
smartphone bot and eventually everybody
that has a website is going to be
migrated over to the smartphone bot and
so with that smartphone bot goes to your
website and starts crawling what do you
think they're looking for their
smartphone bot they're looking for
mobile friendly content if it's not
mobile friendly meaning the page isn't
designed for a smartphone browser or
let's just say the images are way too
large or you have to expand the text
just to read it you know a lot of these
these issues that somebody would have
just simply trying to read something on
a web page on their mobile device
google's not going to grab that content
so you want to make sure it's mobile
friendly so it gets indexed and so if
your website has a responsive design
google will rank your website based on
its performance on mobile devices okay
so you want to make sure that your
website is mobile friendly and if you're
in an interview and somebody asked this
question you could even take it a step
further and say look i'm going to
measure how friendly my wall my website
is for mobile devices and google search
console because google search console
has a report that will show you what
pages on your website are not mobile
friendly and it's not a guarantee but i
can tell you if i'm google and i'm
crawling your site with my smartphone
bob and that page or one of my pages is
not mobile friendly i'm probably not
going to index it or rank it so you want
to leverage that report in google search
console to see what pages are mobile
friendly so that's a little bonus for
you to really impress the interviewer
who asks you this question because how
are you going to know if one of your
pages is mobile friendly or not if you
don't look at a report so keep an eye on
google search consoles
mobile usability report okay number six
list down the most important local seo
ranking factors okay so
organic local ranking is just as
important as anything else in organic
search because if you have a local
business you want to use the likes of
say google my business to show up when
somebody types in you know looking for a
florist or
you're looking for a coffee shop so what
you want to do is you want to create a
web page for every product and service
okay you also want to opt for your
business listings on google my business
and and there are plenty of other local
business directories out there like yelp
for example or bing even has one so go
ahead and also make sure you have a
business listing as well but since
google in the united states has a huge
market share you want to start with
google first you want to update your nap
citations on your website maintain
consistency of your nap okay so nap is
name address phone number so
you want to make sure that that's
current and consistent so if you have a
number on your website make sure it's
the same number on google my business
okay you can embed a google map on your
website you could certainly optimize the
meta tags and content not only on your
web pages but within your google my
business directory so you can add your
business to other local directories like
i mentioned yelp and then also just as
important opt for reviews and ratings
okay so the more reviews the hat you
have the better off you are okay so i
always say this with the with local
search three of the main factors in
showing up for local search on say
google is obviously the key word the
second is the proximity of where that
person is and then third is the reviews
so you can't really control the
proximity but you can control the
keyword and you can control the reviews
to some degree so work hard at getting
reviews for your business but at the
same time you can certainly work in some
keywords let's just say for your product
and service pages on your website but
also you can translate that over to
google my business okay so working in
those keywords making sure you're your
number your address your name they're
all consistent and and really just
spreading your the the business out on
other directors that's really all these
are really key factors for local seo
okay so question number seven
how to avoid duplicate content getting
penalized for duplicate content so for
example if you have two different
versions of a web page you may result in
a duplicate content issue so it's just
seo 101 you never want to have two two
or more pages with the same content so
what do we do well we can avoid this in
having google penalize us by again
setting up a 301 redirect remember three
or ones are permanent we can also use
what they call a canonical tag and a
canonical tag basically alerts the
search engines as to which page is the
original okay so if we have an original
page we want to point to that page with
our canonical tag and then the third
option is opt for preferred domain in
google search console okay so if you
have multiple no names make sure you set
up a primary one and search console so
those are ways to work around it of this
three i would always go with the
canonical tags because that's just a tag
that's going to sit on the page it's
going to alert google as to what the
original is just in case they get their
hands on the duplicate so all the pages
that have the same content are going to
have the same canonical tag pointing to
one page so again three ones are
permanent you can simply just redirect
one to the other if you end up having
duplication or you could just tell the
search engines hey this is the original
page or you can go through search
console okay number eight what are the
tactics to increase a web page speed
okay so what are some of the tactics
well when you build a site especially
for mobile you want to keep it as simple
as possible and what i mean by simple as
possible really i mean hey use a simple
website design don't get overly creative
if you will most websites all websites
have images you're not going to be able
to get around that but just make sure
you optimize your images in other words
don't have such a large image size if
you don't need something very large
don't have it okay you want to improve
server response time what do we mean by
that well your site's sitting on a
server somewhere you can own that server
or you can be renting it out from say
amazon web services or let's just say
godaddy as your register they also have
web hosting well if you have it on say
godaddy server you may be sharing that
server with other businesses and at
certain times of the day other
businesses may get a lot of traffic and
suck up a lot of bandwidth what is that
going to do that's going to reduce the
server response time for your site and
so you want to make sure you have an
idea of you know what server your web
page your website is on and you want to
be able to can have some control over
that because if your server response is
slow that's going to slow down
everything else in terms of loading in
the browser and that's not going to be
good for seo okay optimize your code
what do you mean by optimizing when we
see mimifying we mean get rid of some of
the redundant code if you have css you
know get rid of chop some of the get rid
of the javascript you're not using so
that's what we mean by optimizing code
reduce redirects okay ideally you just
want to have one redirect in place you
don't want to create a daisy chain so to
speak of redirecting and redirecting
after that that's never going to bode
well and it's going to slow things down
as well enable browser caching so if you
enable browser caching basically if
somebody comes back to the page they've
been on say two days ago they're
probably going to see a cache version of
that page and then off for the content
delivery network as well so
these are some of the ways to reduce
page speed now if you're curious about
the page speed of your website you can
always go to google's page speed
insights tool and all you have to do is
just google page speed insights or even
just something generic like google page
speed and you're going to get this tool
page speed insights and all you need to
do is just plug in a url when you plug
in the url google is going to analyze
the url for both mobile and desktop and
so here we could see google gives a
score so we could see the score from
mobile and we could see the score for
desktop just by clicking on desktop and
so here i could see
some of the issues that the site may be
having in terms of page load time for
their desktop if i flip over to mobile
you know here i could see some other
issues for example they have a server
static assets with efficient cash policy
now if you're not sure what the heck
that means you can always just click on
it and you can see some specifics here
anywhere you can just always google it
as well uh here you got to reduce the
impact of third-party code okay so
that's another thing uh reduce
javascript execution time so again going
back to a lot of some of the comments we
met about coding okay some sometimes too
much code or code not functioning as
well as it should will tend to slow down
the site okay so you can use pagespeed
insights you can always get a glimpse of
how pages are loading simply by also
going to for example google analytics
under behavior okay you can go to site
speed and if you click on overview okay
google what google does is they do a
sampling of pages over time and in this
case based on 89 page views they have an
average page load time and so you can
get a sense of how quick specific pages
load your site overall simply by looking
at the site speed overview report in
google analytics to get a sense of how
quick your pages are loading now
there are certain factors that do affect
low time so obviously the way the page
is built with the code the images etc
but also the browser each browser loads
differently okay so you want to take a
look at it by browser also by country
every country has a different network
you can be in the united states and have
worse network service than you do say in
you know
ivory coast in africa okay so really
depends on the network you're on so and
also the page every page is built
differently so you want to get a sense
of what pages are loading quicker and
which pages are not you can simply just
go to page timings and google analytics
and get a sense of what pages do not
load fast which ones do and maybe hone
in on the pages that aren't loading fast
and address those pages first okay so
you have two tools at your disposal one
google analytics and one page speed
insights okay so let's look at question
number nine here so when should an
individual target short tail and long
tail keywords okay so
remember short tail are usually one to
two key words very broad in nature long
tail keywords maybe three four keywords
in a query or maybe an entire sentence
those are considered long tail keywords
so usually short tail keywords have
higher volume but also higher
competition longer tail keywords usually
have lower
volume but also lower competition but
the great thing about long tail keywords
the conversion rate will tend to be a
little bit higher than say a short tail
because it's less vague and more
specific so you can use short tail
keywords if you're trying to drive a lot
of visitors because those keywords are
going to be vague or broad in nature
long tail keywords are used for targeted
pages such as product pages and articles
so if you have a specific product with a
long name you can certainly optimize
that page for that product name again
the product name may have low volume but
if somebody types in exactly that
product name you show up the chance of
you them converting are going to be very
high so you don't have to always be that
specific with the product name but try
and be as specific as you possibly can
in order to get somebody to click on
your link in the search engine results
and get them over to your site to
convert okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for short tail keyword you're probably
going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may not be as high as
something say long tail where hey maybe
you're just toned in on a few set number
of products and you're not care you
don't care a lot about the traffic you
just care about getting the relevant
traffic to your site to convert okay
number ten what are the important
elements to focus while developing a
website so we're talking in terms of seo
okay so if somebody asks me this
question in an interview what am i going
to focus on when developing a website
well the answers are right here yes we
talked about mobile mobile is so
important because a lot of websites are
going to be
indexed with google smartphone bot so
mobile usability is very important so we
need to make sure our website is
responsive for mobile just some basic
practices when it comes to site
architecture and navigation we want to
have a simple url structure okay no
overly cumbersome the navigation should
simply be clean and neat okay if you
have five products okay maybe
you have uh in your navigation you have
something called products with all five
listed or you have all five products in
the main navigation the key is you just
wanna make it clean and easy for
somebody to find the the rule of thumb
is if it's good for the end user
probably going to be good for google but
if complicated for the end user it's
probably going to be complicated for
google you always want to create a
sitemap now what is that sitemap a
sitemap is simply just a formatted file
with to that includes all your urls and
assets your images and your videos
they're going to be sitting on your
server as well so you want google or
these these bots to be able to find your
pages and assets and by the way you want
to take it a step further and make sure
you upload that site map which is
sitting in the root directory meaning
domain.com
sitemap.xml
okay you want to take that sitemap and
make sure you input that sitemap
location in google search console that
way google search console has a one-way
ticket to grab the elements in the
sitemap another important element to
focus on while developing a website is
having a robot's text file and all a
robot's text file is it's like a lock i
always say to a house so if you lock a
door in your house nobody's gonna be
able to get in that door so that's all
what robot's text file is you're telling
google and these other bots that are
coming across your site what's locked
what's not locked meaning what they have
access to what they don't have access to
so you want to be able to make sure you
have a robot's text file if you're
trying to
not index specific pages of your website
because if you tell google don't crawl
these pages or this directory they're
not going to get crawled if they don't
get crawled they're not going to get
indexed so robot's text file is an
important element to focus on while
you're developing your website and while
you're developing your website it could
be on a you know in a directory just
called new website so you probably want
to have new website as the directory in
the robots text file and just to let
google know don't go into this directory
because it's my new website i'm not
ready to go live yet so you don't want
it indexed so
there's a lot of reasons to have robots
text files that's the main reason
sitemap you want google to get these
pages and assets quickly okay you want
to make sure that your site architecture
navigation is in order you want to make
sure your site is mobile friendly and
you also want to make sure you have
content on your website that's the key
because that's what's going to keep
people on the website and engaged and
when i say content i don't necessarily
just mean words i also mean videos i
also mean images you know something
interactive okay you want to keep people
engaged that's the key behind it trust
me if an end user finds your site
engaging google is likely going to find
your site engaging okay so those are
good brownie points to bring up if
somebody asks you this question in an
interview so just to recap here it's
important to have a better site
structure so the bots can easily access
and mix the content with a responsive
design helps to make your website mobile
friendly and user friendly would also
increase the amount of time a user
spends on your website which may improve
your site's ranking sitemap is simply
just a file that helps search engine
bots to understand the structure of the
website okay how many pages are on your
website and where they located along
with the videos and images okay and then
the robots text just instructs the
search engine crawlers to understand
what pages should not be indexed okay
this is simply just a text file and it's
added to the root directory again think
like a door think of a lock okay you can
tell you can lock whatever doors you
want in your house then give it that way
okay so those are our questions for seo
again if you have any additional
questions or if there are other
questions maybe you've been asked in an
seo interview then go ahead and add them
to the comments section below we'd love
to hear from you now we're going to turn
our attention to search engine marketing
so let's turn our full attention to
search engine marketing so we're moving
away from seo and over to pay per click
and so you really have to know your
stuff here you really do uh so a lot of
the questions we're gonna ask gonna be
centered around google ads formerly
known as google ads words and so if
you're familiar with google ads the
platform
then you should have no problems
whatsoever answering these questions but
that's why we're here and that's why
you're watching so
there's anything you want to add to any
of these questions as a reminder feel
free to comment under the video and so
right out of the gate question 11 what
is ad scheduling so ad scheduling is a
feature in google ads and really all it
does is allow you the advertiser to set
up certain hours or days you want your
ads to shout it's as simple as that so
if you have a customer that you're
running
ads for on google search and
let's just say they have a restaurant
and they're closed during certain hours
of the week then you can go into the ad
scheduler and schedule your ads to not
show when they're closed as an example
okay because if somebody calls and
they're not there to answer the phone
then it's not going to be good for the
restaurant or you the advertiser and so
that's why they have the ad scheduling
so it ensures your ads are not running
when they're performing poorly let's
just say
you know you're running a business and
you just don't get that much traffic
during the weekends well you can go in
and adjust accordingly it also there to
make sure you could serve your customers
when you do have limited client service
hours so let's just say you have a
customer service team that's going to
answer phones for a couple hours a day
well again you can schedule your ads to
show during those couple of hours a day
and then really what it comes down to is
you're making sure you can satisfy
customer demand and supply and so that
means showing your ads when you you can
best fulfill the customer's needs okay
and so that's really what it's all about
uh and that's what ad scheduling is so
take advantage of ad scheduling schedule
it according to the business hours
schedule according to how they can best
serve the customer schedule the ads when
it's performing best and don't schedule
the ads when you know you're gonna have
poor performance okay so next question
what are the different ad formats
available on google ads it's a trick
question because it really does come
down to what network you're advertising
on so google has two networks the search
network and the display network okay so
on the search network there's only one
ad format and that's text okay so google
recently
changed the format of the text ads now
they're called expanded text ads so here
you can see you can have up to three
headlines and two description lines and
then you can also have ad extensions and
so you can see here underneath the ad
you have what they call site links so
shop by category in here headphones on
ear headphones those are all site links
to specific pages on the site so
text ads are available only on the
search network but they're also
available on the display network as well
then you have responsive display ads now
responsive responsive display ads are
only on google's display network okay so
here you could see
some samples of responsive display ads
and these ads adjust their size and
format depending on the space available
so again you could have text ads or you
can have display ads now display ads
again come in different sizes so you can
create ads for a variety of different
sizes for example 250 by 250 or 468 by
60. so those are some of the different
ad types there's there's a plethora of
different ad sizes you can choose
however your ads not going to show
on a website if they don't have that
particular size available so it's always
best practice to create different ads
but create ads in different sizes as
well okay and then have a backup text ad
as well just in case the site doesn't
even display a display ad for you or
serve up a display ad so you can have a
text ad as a backup okay so lots of
different ad sizes but this is the
second ad format that's responsive
display and again the responsive part is
google will automatically
show the ad that's best performing based
on a series of headlines descriptions
and images that use you provide google
and so the responsive part is hey if
this combination of headline description
and image work best meaning it has the
best click-through rate then google's
going to serve up that ad so that's why
they call it responsive so
obviously can have just an image ad
that's not responsive again across
different ad sizes you know they could
be again 250 by 250 300 by 300 468 by
six there's a number of different sizes
google can provide you that information
but the one thing to note here is that
when you do create an image ad it could
be
jpeg it could be
interactive or it could be static so
different types of image ad formats like
png for example or it could be a static
or it could be interactive so definitely
take advantage of the different
opportunities uh meaning a static ad
versus an interactive ad you may want to
have two variations of that so you could
see which one works best okay there's
also app promotion ads so these ads are
used to drive app downloads so you're
gonna have to set up a campaign
accordingly okay but here you can see
this is what it looks like with the call
to action so it allows you to go ahead
and click and install that app so that's
an app promotion again if you have an
app and you want to promote it you can
use this type of ad format to align with
a campaign that's driving traffic to
download your app okay and of course you
have video ads well google owns youtube
and so if you have videos you have the
opportunity to advertise on youtube okay
so these ads can be standalone or
inserted into other streaming video
content and so to me video ads work well
with specific strategies and what's one
strategy you would use a video ad for
brand awareness or education explainer
videos and so youtube allows you the
advertiser the opportunity to get your
ad your service your product in front of
a lot of eyeballs so that's the beauty
of video ads they attract a lot of
eyeballs and
definitely help with the strategy of say
brand awareness okay another ad format
going back to the search network is
shopping ads so if you sell shoes then
you may want to think about having a
campaign for shopping so shopping ads
work with google merchants so google
merchant is another google product and
basically google merchant allows you to
manage your inventory so if you have a
hundred different types of shoes that
you're selling you can upload your
inventory to google merchant connects
and talks to google ads so basically
what you're doing you're setting up your
your campaign and google ads and
connecting your inventory from google
merchant to google ads and so the great
thing about
the shopping campaign is it puts your
product front and center it puts the
price it puts any promotion that you
have and it puts the brand all front and
center so when somebody does type in
let's just say lime green sneakers or
women's sneakers and this particular
shoe shows up here the third one from
the left then somebody's gonna see it's
from the united colors of benetton it's
a woman's shoe it's on amazon and it
costs 45 so the great thing about
shopping ads is if somebody's interested
they're going to click okay if
somebody's not interested say well you
know it's a little bit more expensive i
can get something similar
another shoe on amazon for less okay
they're probably gonna click on that
particular ad so again the great thing
about shopping ads put your product
front and center with any promotion the
price the brand so if somebody clicks on
it then they're probably serious buyers
okay so that's the beauty of shopping
ads it allows you to get your product
out there and on the search network it's
a cost per click so you're only paying
for the click so if somebody looks at it
but doesn't click you're not paying for
that so that's the beauty of shopping
ads and so
you can showcase your shopping ads so
these ads have an image and a
description that expand when clicked so
you can provide more information more
product and store information as well
you also have call only ads okay so call
only ads are enabled to users to connect
with your business directly using the
phone number provided okay so it allows
somebody on a mobile phone who in this
example is searching for drywall repair
well if you're in the business of
drywall repair you can have your ad show
up on mobile with the phone number and
somebody can easily click on that phone
number and just call you directly now
the way call only ads work is you're
still getting charged for the click okay
so anytime somebody clicks and calls
you're going to get charged and you're
going to get charged just as you would
if somebody clicked on your ad so it
works the same way so it's a cost per
click again this is on search so search
is cost per click and the beauty about
call only is again
you can track the calls right in google
ads so you can have google ads track how
many people click on the number and you
can even count those calls as
conversions if they meet a certain
criteria for example the criteria is
somebody
talks to you for a minimum of 60 seconds
or one minute then google will count
that as a conversion so you can monitor
calls right in google ads and it's a
cost per click model so you can actually
see what the average cost per click is
so moving on question 13. okay what is
rlsa and how does it work well
rlsa stands for remarketing list for
search ads so if you're familiar with
remarketing on display it's similar they
just call it rlsa okay so it enables you
the advertiser to customize your ads for
people who have visited your site just
like a typical remarketing campaign okay
so you could tailor your bids and ads to
these visitors when they're searching on
google and search partner sites okay so
there are two basic strategies for using
rlsa okay so you can optimize bids for
existing keywords for visitors or you
can bid on keywords that you don't
normally bid on just for people who
recently visited your site or converted
on your site key here is you're the one
that's picking the customer you're the
one that's enabling the list if you're
trying to target people who went to your
site and didn't convert well you could
certainly optimize your bids for
existing keywords for people who went to
your site and didn't convert or you
could set up a whole new campaign for
rllsa and have a different set of
keywords with a different ad because you
know who you're talking to you're
talking to somebody who's already been
to your site they know your brand they
just didn't purchase and so this all
happens on the search network and that's
the beauty of remarketing is one you
know who your audience is because you're
the one establishing that audience and
two you're the one creating the ad so
you can talk directly to that audience
when they see your ad again
in this case on search so that's rlsa
remarketing list for search ads i
recommend pretty much any industry any
client any customer run remarketing list
for search advertising and remarketing
for display so those are two key
campaigns you should always recommend
running to a client because one again
you're defining the audience two
you're the one that's talking directly
to you guns because you know who the
audience is and three if they see the ad
and they click on it again because it's
cost per click then the chances of
converting are going to be higher
because they've already been to your
website they know who you are and so if
they click on your ad again then they
must be interested so those are all the
benefits of running an rlsa campaign
okay so number 14 what types of
audiences can be used in gdn google's
display network so a lot of different
audiences here okay so let's go through
them so you have affinity audiences so
basically affinity audiences are
basically
what are people's interests and habits
what do they have an affinity for are
there food sites travel sites shopping
sites fashion okay so that's what
affinity really relates to okay then you
have in-market custom intent life events
these are what they're researching or
planning for so again it could be travel
it can be finance etc okay you have
remarketing we just went over that with
remarketing lists for search advertising
rlsa and so when the remarketing it's an
audience that has interacted with your
website so they either came from mobile
or came from mobile and didn't convert
or female came from mobile and didn't
convert so you're the one defining the
audience there you also have a similar
audience so this is what google creates
on your behalf so these are users with a
similar interest to your site visitors
so google is monitoring the type of
traffic that's coming to your site and
based on that traffic they're going to
create a similar audience and then you
have a custom match so what you know
about your customers activities
basically so these are all the different
audience types and you can see the
different types of ads available okay so
notice the far right column video ads so
video ads are available to every one of
these audience types why because youtube
so google knows what people's interests
and habits are based on the videos they
watch they know what they're looking for
okay they
you know that they've been to your
website because they're cooking so you
can remarket them okay so video ads are
very powerful tool for any one of these
audience types so next question what are
the types of keyword matching available
in google ads okay so this is a good
question
very important if you're gonna manage a
google ads account and a campaign you
have to be aware of the different match
types you can't just go broad match
that's a sign of somebody who doesn't
know what they're doing is by bidding on
a one keyword phrase that's a short tail
keyword if you think back to seo we have
our long tail and our short tail
keywords the worst thing you could do is
bid on a keyword short tail keyword
that's broad match because what is broad
match basically broad match are keywords
that appear when a user searches any
word in the phrase now you can define
specifically
what you want your ads to appear for in
terms of keywords and when i say
specifically you can use a phrase match
so phrase match are ads that appear only
when a user searches for that exact
keyword phrase in the precise order but
with some additional words in the
beginning or at the end of the query
okay so usually these are sentences so
you could be
you know bidding on red adidas running
shoes and somebody could type in looking
for red adidas running shoes in portland
oregon okay as an example okay so as
long as red adidas running shoes are in
order in that keyword phrase then your
ads going to appear because it's a
phrase match and then you can get really
specific by doing an exact match so
exact match are keywords that are
triggered only when that keyword and
exactly that keyword phrase is queried
so if you do an exact match for
red adidas running shoes and somebody
types in only red adidas running shoes
then that's an exact match and your ads
going to appear so let's take a look at
these again so you got broad match okay
we got a term cheap smartphone so if
somebody types in smartphone cheap phone
smart mobile phone cheap any one of
those combinations your ads going to
appear now there's one thing you can do
for broad match and it's called broad
match modifier so you can put a plus
sign in front of the keyword for example
let's just say you really want to
emphasize the word cheap okay you're
selling really inexpensive smartphones
okay not just any smartphone but an
inexpensive smartphone so you can put a
plus sign in front of cheap and so
somebody puts in you know just
smartphone or smart mobile your ads not
going to show up because the word the
keyword query has to contain sheep so
anytime you put a plus in front of the
keyword query you're bidding on then
that means that keyword has to be part
of the keyword phrase so that's a a
broad match modifier if you will and
that prevents you from getting unwanted
impressions so we have phrase match
again blue smartphone so somebody could
type in smartphone in blue color cheap
blue smartphone notice though the second
one where it says smartphone and blue
color your ads not necessarily gonna
show up because guess what blue
smartphone is the keyword query and your
uh your the query here is not in that
order so remember in order for you to
show up for phrase match the keyword has
to be in that order so i'm looking for a
blue smartphone that is less than 100
okay that could be somebody's query blue
smartphone was in that query in that
order so if somebody says looking for a
smartphone that happens to be blue less
than a hundred dollars then your ad is
not going to show up so remember it has
to be in that ex precise order one thing
i want to go back to on the phrase match
notice that there's quotes around the
keyword anytime you see quotes around
the keyword that signifies a phrase
match because if we look at exact match
notice there are brackets around the
keyword red shoe that signifies is an
exact match so if you put brackets
around a keyword then you're signify
signaling to google that this is an
exact match and i only want to show up
for the keyword red shoe well the only
option that will work here is the second
one red shoes okay so because that's an
exact match okay so disregard the first
and the third one because shoe and red
color is not going to work and footwear
that's red is not going to work because
this is an exact match so you're saying
i only want to show up for the keyword
red shoe and google recognizes plurals
and singulars together so somebody did
type in red shoes then your ad is going
to show up okay so moving on what are
some of the reasons as to why your ads
could have been rejected it happens to
the best of us and if you're writing ads
and they get rejected it could be for a
number of reasons so at the end of the
day you're violating google's
advertising policies so
some of the policies that could have
been violated are and just some of the
many we're just listing some here
prohibited content prohibited practices
restricted content or editorial
technical so when you look at prohibited
content i will say this you're not going
to be able to sell drugs even if you're
selling pharmaceutical products that's
considered drugs and that's going to be
prohibited or prohibited practices like
selling drugs online that's illegal in
the state so
you're going to definitely get flag for
that okay so there are a lot of
different ways in which your ads can be
disapproved okay
but if you do see restricted content
then that means you can advertise but
with limitations and usually those
limitations are restricted to say only
google search and not google search
partners or to a specific geography so
usually the key here is if somebody asks
this question okay there are a lot of
different reasons google's usually going
to provide the specific or the reason
why it got disapproved and they're
usually going to include a link that you
can refer to okay so at least google
does that much they're not going to
leave you in the dark and tell your ads
just been disapproved they're going to
tell you why and include a link that you
can go to figure out how you can best
resolve the disapproved ad so what are
the different kinds of bidding available
in google ads so we already covered part
of this earlier on so remember google
search network is only cost per click
cpc when we talk about google's display
network you have three options cost per
click cost per view and cost per
impression and cpm is cost per 1000
impressions so you're paying per 1000
impressions impression is when somebody
actually sees your ad cost per view
is actually somebody looking at your ad
for at least 30 seconds or the entirety
of the ad so if the ad video ad only
runs 15 seconds and somebody watched the
entirety then you're going to pay per
cost per view so if your video is two
minutes long and somebody watched 30
seconds you're gonna pay cost per view
okay so again let's go through these
cost per click it just enables you to
set up a maximum price on the cost of
somebody clicking on your advertisement
you only pay when somebody clicks on
your ad okay cost per view again this is
the default method to set the price
you'll pay for your video ads okay you
only pay when a viewer watches your
video advertisement for at least 30
seconds and then cost per 1000
impressions so this is the amount you
pay each time your ad is displayed in
the search network and you pay for
impressions that are generated for your
ad and you're paying for every 1 000
impressions so the m is actually the
normal uh roman numeral for 1000 so
that's where the impart comes in so
you're paying for 1 000 impressions so
every 1 000 eyeballs you're gonna pay a
price and so cost per impression is good
for
brand awareness if you're trying to
generate a lot of eyeballs onto your
brand then you'd want to go with a cpm
model okay so question 18 what are some
automatic bidding strategies so let's
define automatic bidding strategy
automatic bidding allows google take
over okay not you google's taking over
and they're the ones setting the bid
amounts automatically and it's going to
be based on criteria and some of that
criteria is going to be centered around
conversions so if google bids on your
behalf automatically basically what
they're doing is they're collecting data
on the behavior of your ads and so if
your ad is likely to get the click or
conversion then google is going to set
the bid amount so you can win that
auction in order to get the click or the
conversion so
there are different types of bidding
strategies but remember you have to
align a bidding strategy with the
strategy of the campaign so for example
if your goal of the campaign is to
increase site visitors you just want
people to click on your ad and go to
your website then you're going to have
an automated bidding strategy of
maximize clicks that aligns with your
campaign strategy
so this strategy automatically sets your
bids to help to get as many clicks as
possible within your budget so google is
going to do its best based on historical
performance of the campaign to generate
traffic to your site that's the goal
that's the biz strategy okay let's take
a look at some others so
hey the goal of our strategy campaign is
to increase visibility so that's an easy
one remember cost per impressions hey we
want to maximize how many people look at
our ads okay so target impression share
so this bidding strategy allows your
bids to show
at the top of the page okay so you're
getting the impression so people are
able to look at your ad okay so you're
telling google hey i want to be shown at
least 50 percent of the time when
somebody types in a keyword that i'm
bidding on so they're going to make sure
that they meet your target impression
share 50 so they're gonna set your bids
automatically to make sure your ad shows
at the top of the page so it's seen at
least 50 of the time that's the goal of
the campaign that's the bidding strategy
goal we set up a campaign to drive
conversions so there are a couple of
bidding strategies against conversions
so target cpa so this strategy sets a
search or display bid to get as many
conversions as possible but there's a
caveat here cost per acquisition is what
cpa stands for so we're trying to get as
many conversions as possible but at a
certain cost for example if i'm selling
t-shirts for ten dollars do i want to
pay twenty dollars cpa for every sale do
i want to pay google 20 no i'd be losing
money i'd be out of business okay so if
i'm selling t-shirts for 10 on my
website i'm probably gonna put the cpa
about two dollars or three dollars again
depending on my cost of goods so if i
factor in my cost of goods i'm trying to
make a profit then i'm going to tell
google look i'm trying to get some sales
but i don't want to lose money getting
the sale so you're going to put in a
threshold and that threshold is your
target cpa and so google is going to
automatically bid and win the auction
for keywords when they feel those
keywords can get you a target cpa that
you put in for example two dollars okay
so the goal of our campaign is to meet a
target return on ad spend meaning return
on advertising spend meaning we're
getting more revenue than we're spending
that ratio needs to be positive so
google's gonna help us again adjust our
bids to make sure that our return on
advertising spend meets our criteria so
we could put a
roas as 100
200 etc and google's going to adjust our
bids accordingly based on the keyword
that they think will meet that criteria
of a hundred percent or 200 percent so
that's target return on advertising
spend and that's there to see if google
can help you generate a profit so we
have another campaign set up we're
trying to get more conversions we have a
budget we want to spend the budget but
we don't we want to get conversions so
this is a giving the bidding strategy
here would be maximize conversions so
this strategy sets bids like all the
others it automatically is going to
adjust your bid that is google it's
going to adjust the bid to help you win
the auction based on historical
performance so if a keyword and
historically has performed in terms of
conversions you better believe google is
going to try and win the auction on your
behalf to get the click to get that
conversion and that's maximize
conversions okay moving on question 19
and this is probably the most important
question that you're going to get if an
interview asks you this question this is
what google ads is all about quality
score so what is quality score so simply
put quality score is a score between 1
and 10 given every keyword you've been
on and basically between one and ten and
space google's giving you the score the
quality score of that keyword and so how
does google come up with that score
between one and ten well there's three
main factors here one is expected
click-through rate the second is ad
relevance and the third is landing page
experience so obviously a higher quality
score the better off you are okay a low
quality score it's not going to bode
well for you and so if you have a low
quality score google actually will tell
you
which of these three components you're
not scoring very well on so you're
either going to get a below average
average or above average for each of
these three components that make up
quality score and i will tell you this
if i were to divide them up into thirds
click-through rate expected
click-through rate is more important
than the other two so that's about
two-thirds of quality score an expected
click-through rate is basically google
saying look other advertisers have been
on this keyword and their click-through
rate has been historically around say
for example three percent so if you
can't get three percent then your
quality score is going to suffer ad
relevance is simply does the ad or is
the ad relevant to the keyword you're
bidding on likewise for the landing page
but the landing page experience a little
bit more subjective because the landing
page has to load well
fast no pop-ups no a lot of external
links nothing spammy no ads being served
up so a lot of factors in landing page
experience google wants to make sure
somebody clicks on your ad that they're
going to have a good experience when
they land on that page and so
quality score is so key here it is very
key because if you don't have a good
quality score the repercussion means
you're going to have to bid higher
because quality score times bid
equals ad rank so for every auction
whoever has the highest ad rank is gonna
be at the top of google search results
so if you have a low quality score let's
just say one and you're bidding four
dollars on that keyword then your ad
rank is four one times four is four so
you gotta keep that in mind because
other advertisers could have a higher ad
rank or better quality scores for that
keyword so again expect a click-through
rate this just shows how likely it is
that your ads will get clicked when
shown for a particular keyword google
expects a certain number here you should
always try to achieve the highest
click-through rate possible and
click-through rate is simply how many
times your ad was seen versus how many
times it was clicked that's all
click-through rate is clicks divided by
impressions so you should always try to
achieve the highest click-through rate
possible that will avoid getting a low
quality score add relevance so add
relevance simply means how relevant is
your keyword to the ad okay so if you're
bidding on reddit adidas running shoes
then make sure your ad discusses and
mentions multiple times naturally red
adidas running shoes okay and remember
with those text ads you have three
headlines you have two description lines
of up to 90 characters you have side
extensions okay you have path one and
path two that meaning you can add
additional keywords to the end of a url
so you have lots of opportunities to
make sure the ad is relevant to the
keyword and then landing page experience
again this is a little subjective but
hey google is going to use landing page
experience to estimate how relevant and
useful your website's landing page will
be to people who not only click on your
web but land on that page so does that
page load fast does it have any
unnecessary pop-ups does it does it have
some quirky external links that looks
spammy okay you got to take all these
things into consideration and think
about the end user here then last
question for search engine marketing so
what are the hard marks of a good ppc
landing page so going back to landing
page experience this is a good segue so
you always want to make sure you have an
attractive and powerful headline on the
page remember it's got to be a nice flow
you're bidding on a keyword somebody
types in the keyword they see your
attractive ad they click on that
attractive ad which has the keyword in
it they click on the ad they go to
landing page they want to be able to see
something very similar to what they
typed in the ad they saw they want to be
able to see it seamlessly on the landing
page and so that attractive and powerful
headline should include that key word
should also have persuasive copy that
can convince prospects to convert to me
bullet points always work here simple
bullet points easy to read easy to
understand easy to just convey the
positives about what you're trying to
sell or convert have engaging media like
videos videos always help because
they're interactive it keeps people
engaged longer or have some really good
images don't just go stock photography
you know complement the video with some
images and then your landing pages
should have enough white space to draw
attention to specific elements on the
page and meaning don't cram the page
together because remember users are also
coming to these pages via mobile so you
got to take that in consideration as
well so cramming your pages full of
content videos and images is probably
not going to bode well so make sure
there's breathing room for people to
read understand and react and those are
hallmarks of a good ppc landing page
some other factors here adding trust
indicators like
some statistical evidence meaning how
many people downloaded your app you can
always have testimonials you know
third-party sales of approval like
better business bureau you know privacy
policy links help okay so you want to
add some things in there that's gonna
you know give you credibility having a
properly designed lead capture form to
collect visitors information is always
helpful if you're trying to get that
conversion then have a lead form make it
simple don't have a lead form with 20
forms or fields you know have a simple
name email address make the phone number
optional and have one feel that they can
type in specific information and then
last but certainly not least have a good
call to action so make sure that call to
action aligns with what you're trying to
do again selling those red adidas
running shoes if they're on sale then
you know make sure the call to action
aligns with that sale you can always say
you have 20 off for the next two days or
you know ten dollars off if you purchase
today so have some good strong call to
action okay let's turn our attention to
email marketing so email marketing's
traditional digital marketing channel
it's been around a while and you're
going to be asked some questions that
are going to encompass a lot of things
related to the delivery of emails we all
check emails on a daily basis we all
receive them sometimes we receive emails
unsolicited sometimes we sign up to
receive emails sometimes we receive
emails from friends sometimes we receive
emails where we're working or previously
worked so most people have an
understanding of email however as a
marketer there's a little bit of a
different twist to it so we have to
understand the intricacies of how email
marketing works so you're going to be
asked some questions and really the
first question here is what's the
difference between a hard and a soft
balanced email so if you're a digital
marketer you're in charge of sending out
lots of emails let's just say thousands
or i mean it could be in the hundreds of
thousands of emails you're going to get
some bounces and so you really want to
know the difference between a hard and a
soft bounce so a soft bounce just means
that the email message reached the
recipient's mail server but bounce back
is undelivered so think of it as
delivering an actual mail to a post
office so it actually reached the post
office but it bounced back because
maybe the
you know person's email box was full
maybe their account was temporarily
disabled or maybe the email server
wasn't necessarily able to handle that
email now hard balance is an email that
that is rejected because it's an email
when it happens when the email has been
permanently rejected so for example
maybe the the the account is no longer
valid and so let's look at some reasons
again as to why a soft bounce would
happen so for example the inbox is full
or
the recipient servers down so reach the
post office but there was a problem
actually getting it into the hands of
the owner so to speak where the hard
balance a little bit different let's
just say that person is no longer
working their email has been deleted or
you the email has been blacklisted
somehow okay a spam or something to that
effect so the email server is going to
identify that and it's not even going to
reach the recipient so
a lot of different ways in which an
email may not make its recipient so not
the most important thing to know here i
just the important thing to know is
listen when you send out an email you
got to pay attention to how many get
bounced back and so
next question here what would you do to
improve the click-through rate of your
email so click-through rate is simply
how many people have seen your email and
how many people actually clicked on a
link in the email so if a hundred people
saw your email but only one person
clicked then it would be a one percent
click-through rate so we want to be able
to make sure we have a high
click-through rate so remember emails
are going to people who likely signed up
to receive your email and even if they
are expecting an email or they're not
expecting an email you still want to
follow some of these best practices here
one is to create a compelling subject
line so you want to make the subject
line something that people are going to
notice take note of or take an interest
in and say hey what's this all about
that's pretty interesting and open the
email so use preview text effectively
obviously you want to make your email
mobile friendly because most people look
at their emails on their mobile phones
you want to create engaging content okay
so the content that's in the email
obviously is going to have some links so
put some strong call to action in there
and that's one of the bullet points down
below place a cta where it's easily
visible so keep in mind mobile users
most people are going to check that
email on their phone so you want to make
sure you have compelling content with
good ctas in a visible location so
always check mobile as well as desktop
obviously in your emails you want to
make them as visual as possible don't
make them so text heavy you can always
segment your emails meaning if you're
sending out an email let's just say to
100 people okay maybe you want to divide
it up boys or girls maybe older or young
maybe you know living in one part of the
country versus another part of the
country i mean those are examples of
segments so break up the email don't
send it to
one mass email to everyone that way you
can personalize the email if an email is
personalized the chances of somebody
clicking on it are going to be greater
and then a b test your emails and when
we say a b test you know you can send
out the same email twice except one
segment's gonna say get one version of
the email the other segment is gonna get
another version of the email and what
are the different versions maybe the
subject line so the subject line is
different on version a versus version b
or maybe the call to action is different
so you always want to
send out different versions of the same
email to a different segmented audience
that way you can actually see
which segment or which version got the
most clicks okay so next question here
is how to inform your customers about
company news and establish a
relationship with your target audience
okay so again how do you inform your
customers about what's going on in the
company and how you're going to
establish a relationship with that
audience who's receiving that email well
newsletters are always the best answer
here so somebody signs up for your email
let's just say they actually purchase a
product from you newsletters are great
way to reach out to that audience to get
them to stay up to date with the latest
product or an improved version of the
product they purchased and then that way
they can come back and continue to
purchase the product so newsletters are
great way to reach out to
your audience and actually talk to your
audience and you're not talking verbally
you're talking to them via email so you
send out that email campaign maybe it's
once a month hey we noticed you bought
this product we have similar products
just like the one you bought or hey you
know if it's a software maybe hey we've
got upcoming updates to our software
make sure you go to the website and get
the updates or we have a new and
improved version so all these things you
want to communicate to your audience via
email that's going to get them to get to
the website and that's going to get them
to you know purchase more
update upgrade whatever so newsletters
the way to go so again some basic tips
here you want to create your newsletter
with 90 educational and 10 percent
promotional so remember you're sending
out a newsletter to people who likely
signed up so you're educating them about
your products always create interesting
subject lines you want whether they know
you or not you want to create the
subject line so somebody's going to
click on it so make sure you design your
emails appropriately okay so if you know
you're sending let's just say baby
products to mothers or expected mothers
in fact this is a real life example
because i used to work at a gap and
baby gap was you know one of the emails
groups i was responsible for so we
created an email template with softer
colors your yellows your your light blue
you know it wasn't black or dark red or
anything that's going to be you know
heavy we knew who our audience was and
we designed the template accordingly and
of course using compelling images so for
selling baby products you're gonna put
baby product images in there i mean it's
common sense but you'd be surprised you
gotta pick and choose your images
carefully especially if you're sending
to an international audience because
images can be misconstrued and just like
we mentioned with the click-through rate
you always want to have a clear cta
always make sure you have a cta in a
visible position because most people are
going to look at that email in a mobile
phone okay and then always make sure you
include your contact information in the
newsletter so somebody knows where to
find you how to contact you where to go
maybe they have a product they want to
return okay so you always want to put
that contact information normally it's
at the bottom of the email but these are
all best practices so
here's some examples okay we got you
know check out the latest cosmetics from
our new collections notice the image and
notice the call to action so you can see
trendy collections you know we got some
other products you may want to buy okay
five important skin care products that
everyone should have view more so you
always want to have that call to action
in a very visible place so define
following metrics open rate
click-through rate and response rate and
forward rate so these are metrics
related to email marketing so you're
gonna have to know what these are so we
already mentioned click-through rate
before when we talked about best
practices for improving the
click-through rate so for those of you
that remember what that is go ahead and
put that in the comment section below
just a little pop quiz for you if
anybody remembers click-through rate but
let's take a look at open rate so open
rate is the percentage of the total
number of recipients who actually open
the email so if you send it to
x amount of people how many people
opened it that would be the open rate so
how many people open it but you're gonna
take out the people who bounced it
whether it's a soft bounds a hard bounce
okay you're not gonna count those people
so
if you have let's just say
20 people open the email and you send it
to a hundred people then and you had
nobody balanced then it would be a 20
open rate okay click the rate again pop
quiz it's just how many people actually
clicked on any of the links in your
email and that's just divided by the
number of of the emails you've sent out
a response rate okay so response rate is
the percentage of the total recipients
who clicked on the link of your email
campaign and actually completed an
action so what is that action well it
could be downloading something watching
something purchasing something so that's
the response rate similar to conversion
rate if you're working in a digital
marketing channel and you're driving
traffic to the site you want that
traffic to do something well it's no
different in email marketing we want
people to take action we're just gonna
divide that by the number of emails
delivered and that gives you your
response rate so let's just say you did
send in 100 emails you did get 20
open it and of this 20 let's just say
one person went on to purchase well
you'd have a one percent response rate
and then a ford rate is simply the
forward rate refers to the rate at which
your subscribers share your email uh
with others friends family etc and you
may have that as a call to action in
your email in fact that's a best
practice so it's just the number of
clicks on a share divided by the total
number of delivered emails and you're
gonna multiply that by 100 to get the
percentage and so most email marketing
platforms do measure forward rate okay
let's take a look at question 25 here
how do we capture inactive customers
what you want to do here is re-engage
subscribers with gamification opt for
subject lines like we have been missing
you or did we do something wrong you
want to run a poll or competition to
re-engage their subscribers again trying
to get people involved these first three
are all about getting people involved so
personalize your emails talk to that
person as if hey look i haven't heard
from you in a while how about coming
back and taking a look at our new
products just as you would a friend so
design always matters especially knowing
that you're talking to customers who
haven't been active okay this is a
segmented audience somebody who's
inactive so you want to have the right
design the right message the right
subject line that fits with that
customer's inactivity so you're going to
try and do everything you can to get
that customer back and then you want to
follow a consistent schedule okay so
ideally when you schedule an email you
want to schedule the best time so you
have to know your audience obviously and
then you can always ask for feedback why
are they inactive why haven't they
purchased in a while so the whole idea
here
from gamification like trying to
you know make a game out of it so make
it competitive to
adding polls to really personalizing it
these are all things that you can do to
get your customers back so 26 so what
are the different ways to segment buyer
personas so again when we talk about
segmentation we're talking about taking
a smaller piece of the entire pie so
what's one way to break up that pie if
you will by geography okay so with
geography you could target your audience
based on that area and it could not
necessarily have to be by a part of the
country it could be all the way down to
the province the state the actual city
the county okay if you live in a small
village okay all the way up to the
continent okay so think about how you
would break out the segment by geography
now obviously if you break it out let's
just say the united states to the
southern part well the southern part you
know in the winter in the united states
the southern part is not going to be as
cold to say the northern part so that
should tell you hey we're going to send
an
email in the winter we're not going to
use snow and blizzards as our theme
we're gonna use probably a little bit of
sun so breaking it out by geography
helps you understand where your audience
lives you also have demographic
segmentation and this is simply just age
education income gender you know where
people work okay nationality anything
that's going to identify that user so
this is the best way to segment if you
know who your audience is by income or
gender i mean you're talking to a group
of like-minded people if they're all the
same age from the same generation then
you could talk to them appropriately and
you're not going to talk to
an older person the same way you would a
younger person so think about
demographic segmentation because it
really helps you hone in on your
messaging then you have behavioral
segmentation so behavioral is based on
your audience's behavior have they
purchased before have they never
purchased were they searching for
something how long did they stay on the
site what products were they looking at
are they a lifetime customer so you can
look at behavior and decide how you want
to break out your emails by behavior and
this is a really good way if you're not
even sure who your audience is or where
they live and how old they are you could
certainly break out your audience by
behavior because you know who these
people are based on what they've done
previously because you're going to track
that information with analytics so you
know one way is obviously if somebody's
purchased that's a good way to segment
because you know these people believe in
you believe in your business believe in
your product so the way you can message
to somebody who's purchased before is
going to be different than somebody you
don't even know who they are if they
purchased or not okay so behavioral
segmentation to me is one of the easiest
things the easiest ways to segment your
email list 27 how would you drive repeat
customers through email marketing for
the below scenario
okay so this is a pop quiz if you will
again for those of you that got
click-through rate correctly kudos let's
see if you can go two for two here okay
so if you know the answer to this go
ahead and comment below but let's just
say give a few examples of subject lines
to drive engagement for audiences based
on the following if i had an audience
between 20 and 30 years old that were
female and the product were sandals okay
what would some of your subject lines be
so i'm going to give you a minute to
think about that and put it in the
comment section below now remember this
is an interview based question so you're
going to have to think on the spot i'm
going to give you a minute but if
somebody presented that to you in an
interview you need to be able to you
know react fairly quickly and come up
with some really attractive subject
lines here okay so here you go here's
another one uh so give a few examples of
subject lines to drive engagement for 20
to 30 females for footwear so you got
friday sale coming up buy branded
sandals at the lowest price okay so i
like this one because it's got a strong
call to action buy here you go this is
even better because 50 off on branded
sandals and free shipping i mean who
can't beat free anything including
shipping and if it's 50 off i mean these
are key things you're putting the
promotion and percentage off all in the
subject line so that's really going to
grab somebody's attention we can see for
women starts now okay with a little
emoji that never hurts so those are all
good subject lines they all tend to work
because they all have an element of a
best practice in there so
here you got you know the friday sale
coming up is just giving people notice
okay the stronger call to action on the
buy you're putting the promotion in the
subject line and you know using an emoji
to really just drive home the point so
all these subject lines will work and
hey at the end of the day remember you
want to test your subject lines okay
moving on to the next question speaking
of testing what is a b testing and give
some examples of a b testing okay so we
talked a little bit about a b testing
with subject lines so simply a b testing
when it comes to email marketing it's
just a method to analyze which of the
two email campaign strategies is most
effective all right now you're gonna do
it based on open rate you can do it by
saying click rate you can do it based on
response rate and remember you're
putting one version of the email against
another version whether that be the
subject line whether it be the content
call to action whatever so that's
ideally what you're trying to do you're
trying to figure out what works for your
audience that's the end goal for email
for a b testing and email marketing
what's going to work and i would highly
suggest you should always do a b testing
for subject lines always so some of the
variables that you can test again
subject lines okay you always want to
try if you got a promotion hey will the
percentage off work likely it will but
let's test it up against something else
like you know a generic word like
discounts you can always test the design
you can always test the personalization
the preview text you could try out
images call to actions exclusive offers
what particular offer is gonna work okay
so if you're testing offers then
obviously that's going to be response
rate if you're testing ctas and that's
going to be click-through rate if you're
testing subject lines that's going to be
open rate so you want to be able to test
different elements of the email to
figure out what works and what doesn't
work okay so how to prevent email from
getting into spam so if you're an email
marketer this is your worst nightmare
you don't want your emails to get
spammed so that doesn't bode well for
you so most email marketing platforms
like mailchimp or constant contact
measure spam so some of the important
ways to prevent this is hey improve your
open rate remember going back to the
first question second question you want
to have really good subject lines here
okay and you want to segment your
audience so if you're if you know who
you're talking to and you have a cool
subject line that's going to get
somebody to react and open and that's
going to prevent somebody from spamming
your email okay you can always customize
your from to make it look like it's
coming from in this case rob sanders
check if you have included an
unsubscribe link okay so give people the
option to unsubscribe they don't have
the option to unsubscribe they could
just report you as spam make sure your
emails work on different devices okay
you want to optimize your images for
email make sure they're not big and they
don't fit on a mobile device okay prefer
more text and fewer images and then
avoid grammatical issues you want to
come across as professional you don't
want somebody looking at your email like
who sent this why you sent it to me i
don't want to hear from you again i'm
going to spam you you want to prevent
that and that means a professional
looking email professional content with
a really good subject line and some
imagery to go along with that hey you
may just get somebody to open that email
and get them to convert that's the idea
behind it so these are ways to prevent
somebody from actually spamming you and
then what are the best practices for
email subject lines so the subject
line's the most probably the most
important element in email marketing so
we talked about that little pop quiz
with the sandals targeting 20 to 30 year
old women you know to me i like the
subject line with the 50 off so that was
a number in the subject line so people
can actually see hey wow i get a whole
50 percent that works better than just a
discount okay remember one of those
subject lines had an emoji so don't be
afraid to include emojis in there for
example when i send out emails using you
know during the spring you might want to
use flowers perhaps to signify hey it's
spring winter's over so personalize the
subject lines remember that goes with
segmenting so if you know who your
audience is your your subject lines can
be a little bit more personal okay so
opt for title case subject lines okay so
instead of making it grammatical for
example okay you want to keep your
subject lines short and to the point
remember you want to say something
that's going to draw somebody's
attention if you make it long and drawn
out and boring then people aren't going
to open it develop a sense of urgency
like hey we got 50 off through friday so
that's a little sense of urgency so
people know hey if it's thursday i
better open this email and check it out
and again grammatical mistakes that goes
without saying you always want to
preview your emails before you send them
out so if you preview your emails before
you send them out have somebody else
obviously receive the preview they can
be another set of eyes for you to
prevent any mistakes but also give you
feedback on the imagery the design etc
okay so these are all best practices for
good subject lines okay so subject line
is the most important element for email
marketing so just keep these in mind
subject lines and having good subject
lines is the way to get people to open
it and from there that's half the battle
somebody can open the email then you've
just set yourself up for better
performance okay let's turn our
attention from email marketing to social
media marketing one of the interesting
channels hot trend channel a lot of
people want to get into social media
marketing a lot of jobs available but
you have to know what you're doing so
let's get into it uh and here's some
questions you might be
asked in an interview related to social
media marketing social media marketing
is very interactive
a lot of people posting information
whether it be a tweet a post uh sharing
liking engaging commenting i mean a lot
of things going on in social media so
some of it is gonna probably be good
most of it's probably gonna be good but
every once in a while you're gonna get a
negative comment so
you're probably going to be asked this
question how do you respond to negative
comments well very simple you got to be
quick to acknowledge okay don't sit on
it you know don't waste time
him and hot how you're going to respond
you really have to acknowledge the
comment and start the process of
constructive engagement to turn the
negative experience into a positive one
so let me just expand on that for just a
second we know you like your brand we
know you like your product we know
you're very proud we get that i'm proud
i like to defend sometimes my beliefs
however you got to put that aside when
it comes to social media
why because everybody is watching you
and everybody can read what you write so
you the spotlight is on you not
necessarily the consumer the customer
who wrote the negative comment so you
really have to be cognizant here and
conscientious of what you post in
response so be quick but be constructive
because you want to turn that negative
into a positive that's really what it's
starting with so how do you do that well
how do you be constructive well see it
from the customer's point of view take
off your ownership hat if you will your
manager hat and put on the customer's
hat always look at something from
somebody else's perspective try to
understand why that person wrote that
negative comment and ask yourself how
you can make it right so if you're the
customer and you are your customer when
you go to the store and buy food you're
the customer when you go to the store
and buy clothes when you buy a car
you're the customer so ask yourself what
you can do
to make it right why you're thinking in
the customer's perspective or looking
through their eyes if you will to me
it's it's not an easy thing to do but
it's something you have to do okay so
always look at it from a customer's
point of view and then take it out of
the spotlight so
really because everybody's looking at
you waiting to see how you respond and
remember this customer that wrote the
negative comment can certainly share
your comments to the world so you got to
be really really careful i mean how many
times have we seen on youtube you know
poor customer experience going viral on
on via video so you just gotta really be
careful here so take it out of the
spotlight so offer to resolve the
customer's problems in an appropriate
forum offer up your phone number an
email give them a link to a feedback
form or get their email or phone number
and call them these are the best ways to
really bend this into a more positive
experience for the customer i mean at
the end of the day could become
something really small and silly but
don't make a mountain out of a mall hill
if it is something small and silly how
you respond could make it and see more
than what it really is so be quick be
constructive look at it from the
customer's point of view and offer as
much support as you possibly can okay
that's how you want to respond if
somebody asks that question in an
interview some other comments here so
keep track although the issue might be
solved it doesn't necessarily mean the
commenter has gone away so follow up
with them if you resolved it follow up
with them a month later hey surprise
them two months later give them a
discount okay you'd be surprised
positivity goes a long way and it's
always nice when somebody actually
follows up with you after the fact just
to make sure they want to know that
you're taken care of and then don't feed
the social media trolls okay so ignoring
trolls across social media will make
sure they don't enjoy the notoriety it
brings so don't even allow the
negativity to feed itself so that's why
you really have to stay quick
constructive you know look at it from a
customer's point of view and just turn
this whole experience into a positive
experience it's an opportunity for you
to hone your skills let's move on to
another question so somebody may ask you
to give an example of a successful
social media campaign okay so if you're
going in to interview for social media
manager job you probably want to do your
homework in advance look at what other
people have done so here's a good
example spotify you can see the spotify
ad here with ed sharon spotify mind the
search and playlist data of its user
base to develop a thematic branded ad
experience on billboards in 18 markets
around the world first of all let's just
take this and break it down and sharon's
popular you can see here be as loving as
the person who put 48 ed sheeran songs
on their i love ginger's playlist so
messaging is everything okay and then
you could see what spotify did they mine
the search and playlist data of its user
base okay so they try to understand
their audience going back to email you
gotta understand your audience okay then
they use that to develop a branded
experience on different markets around
the world so they took an audience and
they really marketed this around the
world okay to something that was really
hot and trendy i'd love to see how this
thing actually performed my guess is it
did perform fairly well because when
you're spotify you're gonna pick
something hot and trendy to get people
to react and so to me this seems like
just on the surface a very successful
social media campaign here's some other
things you could see these ads were
featured on the sides of buildings
subway platforms along busy streets so
it wasn't just digital per se i mean
they really went full bore on the
billboards and those billboards were
everywhere on the sides of buildings
again in 18 different markets so you can
see it wasn't just necessarily ed
sheeran per se but you know they had
some good messaging and gr enjoy green
light at every red light that's pretty
cool i guess if you're stuck in traffic
in the middle of a city less fake news
more fake magic so they really took and
honed in the type of music put some good
messaging behind it and really put it
out there so it doesn't always
necessarily have to you know necessarily
be digital per se but they what they did
was they did post this on the sides of
buildings and subway platforms and
throughout different city streets for
maximum visibility for their fans to
upload to their social media okay so do
your homework okay and on this next
question you certainly want to do your
homework so if you're a social media
manager you're probably going to be
involved in some facebook advertising
okay so this is a basic straight up
question what are some of the different
types of ads you can run on facebook you
know you can do single image ads most of
us have probably seen that you can do
multi-product lead ads slideshows
collection ads video ads i mean you got
all sorts of a variety of different ad
formats here okay so let's take a look
at these ad formats single image again
most of us have seen it okay it's just
simply a single image that you know how
allows you to put some text at the top a
link at the bottom or linked to your
website or your facebook page and a
strong call to action okay so facebook
has that built into their ad platform
okay so the ad images need to be 1200 by
628 pixels that's a pretty nice size
image multi-product ads so multi-product
ads are
represented in carousel form so
basically allows you the end user to
view the range of products just by
scrolling and notice each one of these
products has a call to action so here
you can see simply learn offering up all
the different courses they have to offer
so if you have a customer that has
multiple products this is probably the
way you want to go so video ads are very
popular on facebook so video ads usually
range from a few seconds all the way up
to 120 minutes and again video is very
engaging if you have video use the video
okay because they receive about 10 to 30
more views than other forms of ads okay
who doesn't like engaging with video
pretty simple you have lead ads so lead
ads allow you to obtain user details
like name phone number email right in
facebook's environment so it allows you
to collect information right then and
there so lead ads can be effective if
you're trying to get people to sign up
for something slideshow so we looked at
those multi-product ads where you had
the carousel slideshow simply just
allows you to rotate different creative
with nice imagery so the key here is
nice imagery okay you want to put your
best foot forward choose the right
imagery just like going back to the
email marketing you know going back to
pay-per-click you want to use some
effective ads here and images in the ads
okay you also have collection ads that's
another option on facebook so collection
x ads combine video slideshow or product
images taken from your product catalog
so i would recommend this for users who
want to advertise several of their
products at once okay again simply learn
has a lot of different courses a lot of
different thousands of courses so you
know collection ads works for them you
can see here you got social media
certification you got ppc certification
seo certification okay these are all
different certification courses you
could take it simply learn and they want
to go ahead and promote all those
courses together so lo and behold
collection ads offers the best option
here so pay attention those different ad
formats on facebook okay next question
how can you use the holiday season for
social media marketing well this is a
nice segue from the previous question
because you know you have on facebook
all these different ad types so you can
change your ad placements to ones lesser
used by other advertisements you can
also set up clear simple and compelling
offers for your users the holiday season
you're likely going to have some sales
and again make sure your images have
under 20 of text okay that's a standard
across the board but again you want to
have nice imagery so think about all
those different ad formats on facebook
think about the holiday season and how
you can accentuate your ads here okay
i'm thinking video here i'm thinking a
promotion in the video i'm thinking a
collection ad where you can run
different products maybe with a
promotion with some nice imagery during
the holiday season so you definitely
have a plethora of options not just on
facebook but across social media for the
holidays because normally you're going
to have promotions some other things you
can do to
really maximize the holiday season for
social media and that's make
advertisements emotionally resonate with
your audience the holiday season is a
time
really where you reflect on the air you
get together with friends and family and
it's religious and you know it's a feel
good in some parts of the world the
weather changes so you want to resonate
on that okay you want to resonate on
that emotion okay you always holiday
season or not you want to monitor
reports to scale successful ad campaigns
and obviously the ones that aren't
performing you want to pause okay so
with the holiday season you're likely
going to have an uptick in traffic and
uptick in eyeballs so pay attention you
don't want to spend money for money sake
so on facebook it's a cost per click
model so you don't want to be generating
clicks without seeing any results so go
ahead and pay attention maximize those
ads that are performing and get rid of
the ones that aren't okay and then
connect the holiday with your products
or services so again think about which
ones you're going to accentuate which
ones you're going to make more prominent
during the holiday season again thinking
back to the facebook ad types i'm
thinking carouseller collection ads if
you can really pump up some of your
products and have a nice promotion with
them you can run some nice collection
ads on facebook moving on to the next
question so somebody may ask you hey how
do you make content go viral okay i
always wondered that myself how does
content go viral it's a great question
so really you're not in necessarily in
control but you can certainly do some
things to make it more appealing for the
end user to go ahead and share it i mean
that's what going viral is right a lot
of people sharing it because the more
people that share the more people are
going to look and find it just as
enticing and they're going to turn
around and share it so how do you start
that process really is what it comes
down to well create short form content
short form content is more likely to go
viral in other words a 10 minute video
is probably not going to resonate with
somebody something cute funny
interesting unique out of this world in
15 30 seconds is probably gonna go viral
so what does that mean make the visual
content like images and video it works
better than bodies of text so make sure
those images and video are really
compelling and then run giveaways to
draw attention and generate brand
awareness and engagement so you can
always
incentivize your users with a giveaway
or some type of promotion that's going
to maybe pique somebody's interest you
know share it with a hundred friends and
get 10 off as an example so these are
some of the things you can do to make it
go viral of course if you're trying to
get something to go viral you definitely
want to monitor behavior and then tweak
once you figure out how it's performing
okay you may have chosen the wrong
images you may have the wrong promotion
you may find that the contents a little
bit longer than you probably like and
you may want to cut it down some other
things you could do here is use some
trending hashtags and topics on your
post so ride that wave if you will for
any surfers in the audience hey two
people can ride the same wave so if you
got a trending hashtag use that hashtag
with that video or post you can always
ask users to interact okay so you can
always ask them to like or share
especially if they're your audience
because when somebody actually shares it
that means they're sharing it with
somebody else who also has an audience
so that's a quick way to get the ball
going so speak the ball bouncing okay so
next question which industries perform
better with different platforms great
question there's a lot of different
social media platforms you got your most
popular ones all the way down to your
least popular ones i mean let's face it
social media platforms are also
geographic so some social media
platforms are more popular in say the
united states than say india russia and
vice versa we know china has a lot of
different social media platforms that
most americans in the united states
don't even use so you got to keep that
in mind but we're not talking about
geography we're talking about industry
so you got to also think about industry
here so
generally facebook it's usually food and
beverage news and media e-commerce those
are the types of industries that you
might tend to see on facebook when we
talk about e-commerce you know it could
be clothing it could be you know
restaurant okay selling or it could be a
a food company selling you know foods
and beverages you also have instagram so
instagram tends to be more beauty food
and beverage ecommerce so when we talk
about beauty we're talking about clothes
we're talking about makeup you know
maybe shoes dresses unique styles i see
a lot of that on instagram and then
linkedin for example generally works
with you know for me i look at linkedin
as b2b okay so anything you know
interesting in a specific industry
you're probably going to see some news
items and updates on that tips and best
practices and of course jobs a lot of
recruiters on linkedin so linkedin's a
good place for you to really put
yourself out there to find that job you
seek that social media manager job okay
so here's a breakdown if you will of the
top five again in the united states you
know for those users who are watching
this from another country you know you
may find i'll be interested if you could
get some feedback here you know in the
comments section of the video go ahead
and put you know the social media
platform you use in your country and
generally what do you see on that
platform do you see food and beverage do
you see gaming or entertainment do you
see e-commerce so
share your thoughts and knowledge with
the rest of us so next question how
would you measure social media marketing
success of an organization and this is a
likely question a question you're likely
going to get okay how do you measure
success and that's across the board not
just social but ppc email marketing
display
affiliate so really you're always going
to have the right answer if you talk and
think about conversion so with
conversions about tracking content
downloads or sales or registrations or
legion or form submissions anything
where you're going to get something in
return okay so to me that's the general
answer here you know how do we measure
success well it always depends on
strategy but if you're trying to get a
sale from instagram based on your beauty
product or you got a promotion you're
running on facebook and you're running a
lead form type ad okay are you getting
people to enter in that enter in details
on the form submission do you always
want to track conversions from that
perspective okay you also have
engagement okay so your strategy may not
be conversion maybe your strategy is
simply brand awareness and engagement
you want to know how many people
participate in the conversation for
example you may post something that's
really you know hot trends it's trending
it's it's political it could be business
it could be a world affair you want to
be able to measure how many people react
how many people comment reply repost
retweet share like etc so engagement
metrics vary across different social
media platforms but basically when it
comes to engagement you can measure it
just has to align with the right
strategy you also have awareness again
if you're just simply in it for brand
awareness okay it's all about how many
people are actually looking at it the
total volume of people okay and how
widely your message is spreading okay
what's the reach it could also be just
simply traffic to your website so you
can certainly track traffic to your
websites by clicks or shares so it
doesn't always have to be about
conversion or engagement it can simply
hey we want to drive traffic to the
website it's at 37 what are some things
to focus on when advertising on twitter
okay you can advertise on twitter
whether you knew that or not now you
know twitter is a platform where you can
pay for advertising so
what do you want to focus on when you do
advertise on twitter well you want to
emphasize urgency to make sure users
take immediate action you want to
express discounts and percentages why
well because you're limited in what you
can say on twitter you want to avoid
using hashtags that don't pertain to
your brand and product i know that may
sound like common sense but remember
you're advertising in here so you got to
be really really really careful because
you're paying you're paying for somebody
to either look at that ad or click on
that ad so some other things you want to
keep focus on is your ad copy it's got
to be short and to the point and then
make sure your ads are mobile friendly
again just like most social media
platforms twitter is no different people
are looking at twitter on their mobile
phones so video ads should have
subtitles images in the proper ratio so
you always want to think mobile mobile
mobile mobile because most people are
using mobile on their mobile phones
whether that be in the browser or via an
app okay next question how can you use
social media to promote your event okay
so you got an event coming up i want to
promote it so you're going to turn to
social media and the first thing you do
is have affiliates fans and attendees
share resources about the event okay use
leverage your community in other words
okay you can remarket the event to
potential attendees using facebook ads
so you can do remarketing and
remarketing is basically hey somebody
who's seen it or been there or done that
you're retargeting those people you can
use photos of attendees and social
updates so depending on the event you
can have some really high profile
attendees speaking at the event or just
attending the event so use photos to
drive excitement about the event okay
you can create a uniform hashtag that
can be shared across multiple channels
you can mention the event all social
media bios so don't just limit it to one
you know cross promote it on twitter
linkedin etc and what you could do is if
you've run other events in the past
create a highlight rail from prior
events you know show people hey your
events are the events you must attend
they're the go-to events because they
popular they're successful good
attendees usually good attendance and
then some other things you could do here
share behind the screens visual content
and again you could share pictures of
guest speakers along with their quotes
okay so you want to do everything
possible at your at your disposal
especially on social media to really
pump up the event next question how can
you perform a b testing on your ads so
for those of you that listen intently on
the email marketing part remember a b
testing is key with email marketing what
are we tested in email we're testing
subject lines we're testing layout we're
testing call to action so the same thing
here on social media you want to do
continuous a b testing to figure out
what works and doesn't work it's very
simple the great thing about facebook is
they got an a b test feature built in so
you can certainly test different ads
great thing about facebook i like is
that you can simply start out with an
app by running an a b test you could
simply test the imagery it could be a
male versus a female you could test the
call to action a lot of things you could
test so things you can change are again
color of the elements you could change
the positioning you could change the
audience you're targeting the call to
action i mean everything everything
because the whole point is you want to
see which one works which one doesn't
work so testing can be done initially on
broader elements and then smaller finer
details like statements in your ad copy
so you could start out big just by
testing the imagery and so the female
tends to work better than male then you
know what works in terms of imagery well
take the next step and start honing it
on say the message and then once you
figure out what message works then you
can move to the next element like cta
some interesting questions you may get
include what are some things to focus on
when setting up your ad creative this
goes back almost to the a b testing you
want to use ad creative that's attention
grabbing and relevant for your business
so use a primary but bold color scheme
so you also want to you stay away from
clipart okay so again align your imagery
really is important on social media
don't use some basic cheap clipart you
don't necessarily always have to use
stock imagery either i mean it could be
imagery you took that's very relevant
and unique to your product but if you do
that don't use low resolution pixelated
images use images that are well lit so
decide on the aesthetic you want for
your creative clean and minimal or
colorful and vibrant it really depends
on you know the advertisement what it is
you're trying to promote so some other
things to focus on here to create
attention grabbing ads show images of
people benefiting from your product and
coca-cola has done this forever when
have you never seen a coca-cola
commercial with somebody with a smile on
your face drinking a bottle of coke i
don't think i've ever seen an
advertisement so when it comes to food
you should always have somebody in there
enjoying the food if it comes to clothes
should have somebody looking like they
really enjoy wearing these clothes and
they look great in them you want to
accentuate that with you know some nice
coloring sticking with your brand
guidelines okay so imagery really is
important here so you do need to make
sure the ad works for your brand without
requiring explanatory copy the image
should basically speak for itself okay
so let's finish up with content
marketing content marketing another big
digital marketing channel a lot of work
out there so if you're going in for an
interview let's review some of the
questions you may get asked okay so
starting out what are the essential
components of a good web content okay so
essential components okay so what do we
want our content to do well we want it
to be useful so web content should be
written in a way which caters to what
the reader wants okay so somebody's not
gonna read your content if it's not
useful for them okay this because it
affects reader engagement okay so if
it's not interesting it's not useful
somebody's just not gonna read it plain
and simple it also has to be engaging so
listen even if it is relevant to a user
you still have to write the content so
it's engaging so you want to add
elements like imagery videos hey you can
even turn your content into an
infographic okay you want to do
something that's going to be engaging
for the user if it's engaging they're
going to read it and engage with the
content okay and then good content
should have some call to action so
content must be written in a way that
can drive call to action okay so if
you're writing a blog post you know i've
seen a lot of blog posts
just simply start and with good content
but it doesn't leave the user with
anywhere to go so have that call to
action put some internal links in that
content give somebody a place to go
after done engaging with the good
content you write okay so some other
things to think about some other
components for good content well
credibility so you know anybody can
write but are you writing about
something you know what you're writing
about are you a good talking point a
good expert or have experience about
this content so you also want to use you
know information from a legitimate
source okay so you don't want to grab
something in your and use it in your
content that's just not legitimate
because it does hurt your credibility
and the organization's credibility and
then also originality i mean write
something
that nobody else has written so
obviously you don't want to plagiarize
because if you plagiarize and there are
tools out there where people can easily
just put their content in there to see
what else is out there see if somebody
else has plagiarized it so it's very
easy to find people who plagiarize so
don't be that person what i would
recommend create a good content calendar
and come up with some ideas before you
write them next question related to
content marketing so what are the types
of content you can create well there are
a lot of things you can create start
with the blog blog to me is always a
great place to start it's a blank canvas
for your ideas your thoughts your
opinions okay that's a great thing about
a blog it accentuates personality you
can create a video videos are always
engaging you can create an infographic
infographics to me are you know hidden
gem instead of somebody reading the same
old same old you're laying this out in a
very visual way that's easy to
understand create a case study okay so
if you're a digital marketing expert
you've done social media for another
client you know write about it you know
show the successes show that you are an
expert show that you've created
successful campaigns and social and in
the form of case study you can create a
white paper white papers are good
educational pieces you can also create
an ebook okay ebook hey if you have a
lot of content you want to lay it out
and ebook's a good way to go and you
have a lot of choices here when it comes
to content a lot of choices okay so what
are the advantages of having a content
counter so i alluded to that just a
couple of seconds ago so let's really
break this down here because content
counters to me are so important well
first of all calendar part of content
calendar allows you to think about dates
so
if you're planning something you're
going to have important dates in mind
okay so content calendar it almost
ensures you don't miss anything you know
that's a good opportunity for you to
leverage like you know black friday
cyber monday you know it's probably
important you know when those days are
if you're an e-commerce so that's why
having a content calendar helps it helps
you plan out your content based on
important dates or based on dates that
work for what you're trying to do they
also help because you could stick to a
consistent schedule okay so if you don't
have a content calendar you're probably
just arbitrarily writing content here
and there well what if your users crave
and really engage with the content
they're going to want more sticking to
something consistent is going to really
get people to come back for more they
know when you're going to post they're
going to be waiting for it and if it's
every tuesday morning 8 o'clock hey post
it tuesday morning 8 o'clock your users
will get used to that schedule and it
does help build up your following it
does help help build up your community
and in the end cultivates a long-lasting
relationship and then having a content
calendar also allows you to mix up your
content okay so you can see and plan
ahead different types of content in
different formats that way it allows you
to mix it up whether it be a blog post
uh an infographic a video about
different topics okay some other
advantages here saving time it just
allows you to prepare for the future
when you can prepare you're efficient
and when you're efficient you're not
wasting time and so to me having a
content calendar is a must because a lot
of us are busy who has time especially
if you're going to work in a new company
let's say writing content you definitely
want to have a content counter because
you're going to want to use that time to
efficiently plan this is a new company
you're going to start working at you
want to understand who this company is
what they've done in the past what you
haven't done and what you want to do
okay so all of that helps you plan and
prepare and it saves you the time and
effort and hassle down the road and then
at the end of the day you want to be
able to figure out what works so
planning your post puts less strain on
you and your team members as well as
company resources because when you plan
and you post you're going to get data
and then when you get data it's either
going to work or not work and if it
doesn't work then you know in the future
you're not going to put that piece of
content or the topic in the content
calendar again it's that simple okay
some other advantages fresh content okay
so having a con content calendar allows
you to always keep content fresh again
you're gonna be on a consistent schedule
and you're not gonna be writing about
the same things over and over again so
it could be just simply twitter if
you're putting a content calendar and it
together for twitter well you don't want
to have the same tweets every other day
so it does ensure that you're getting
tweets out there that are fresh that are
new that are different and again figure
out what works a content counter makes
it easier to measure results and
optimize performance so you always want
to you know maybe put some metrics in
with your content calendar so you can
see side by side content historically
that is performed content that is not
performed okay so next question you may
get what type of content works in each
stage of the customer life cycle so you
have awareness engagement purchase
post-purchase advocacy okay so let's
break these down here so awareness okay
so you want people to understand who you
are okay that could be a guest blog an
influencer helping y'all it could be a
cold email a v a video that can
potentially go viral a social media post
introducing a product you have
engagement so you want people to engage
with your content what are you going to
do to get people to engage well you
could certainly write an email and have
people open that email and go to your
website you can have an ebook where
people can actually download and read it
or you can have a blog where people can
comment or landing page where they can
fill out a form submission you have a
valuation so with social media we know
there's a lot of engagement going on but
when you're putting content out there
you can certainly open it up to
testimonials okay you can generate white
papers okay or you can generate case
studies case study is a good way for
companies to evaluate what you've done
in the past if you've worked in it for a
specific product in the past and it's
worked you certainly want to put that
out there for potential clients in that
same industry purchase trying to get
people to purchase what are you going to
do well you can certainly have landing
pages a nice you know website a nice
shopping cart with some nice content
okay onboarding emails get those emails
out there and get people to go back to
the website and purchase of course you
can have product and service details as
well meaning you know one one page
downloadable pdfs that describe the
product okay you post purchase okay so
people who've already purchased you can
certainly send out follow-up emails and
you can do blog roundups you know give
people an opportunity to see what
features or updates are happening to the
product okay of course case studies of
repeat customers or content types that
detail a new feature or service okay so
if somebody's already purchased and you
may want to send them some content of
another product that complements the
product they bought so a lot of things
you can do to engage with your user
who's already purchased and then
advocacy you want people to help you out
here so have the user generate the
content you can have exclusive discounts
for your community they're gonna be your
advocates so give them exclusive
discounts and then pictures of customers
engaging with your products okay who's
not going to share that so you're going
to have people share that information in
other words you can generate content
where hey people can help you out here
and be your advocate okay so how do you
decide what topic and subject to write
on okay well going back to the content
counter that always helps you to see
what you put in that content calendar
but there are some other methods you can
use and you could certainly identify
your target audience and not only
identify your target audience but what
their needs are okay so you can write
content based on audience you could
certainly do some research with keywords
okay what's trending what keywords are
not trending okay and right around
what's trending for example okay you
could certainly take a look at social
media for example cora i always look at
korra core is interesting entertaining
informational hey people are certainly
having conversations on core and you can
certainly analyze those conversations
because they certainly get in depth and
you can decide hey do i want to write a
topic around something that really just
won't go away in terms of conversing
core is a good example of analyzing
conversations they tend to be a little
bit more in depth so some other things
you could do you can look at your
competitors and what kind of
conversations are happening on your
competitors blogs or your competitors
social media platforms and pages you can
keep track of blogs and articles from
subject matter experts commentators
critics and so on okay so you can get
ideas from them another question you may
get which is very important if you're
going to start working for a company you
need to understand the tone the tone of
your content because that is going to
fit and be in line with the company
you're working for okay so you're always
going to have a brand personality so the
characteristics of a brand are the
guidelines based on which the content
strategy is developed the tone of the
content must align itself to the content
strategy your audience profile so you
got you need to determine who your
audience is okay and how the brand wants
to be seen by that audience so you know
if you have an older audience you're not
going to use younger audience i.e street
lingo or today's lingo and and the
younger generation uh you're going to
use you know language that's going to
fit the audience you're talking to and
then of course the channel itself so the
content you create must be irrespective
of the channel and consistent with brand
attributes okay so you gotta pick and
choose the channel if it's linkedin for
example hey you know linkedin is more
business oriented okay so you're not
gonna be
you know as humorous as you would be say
on instagram or facebook all of these
have one thing in common again that's
brand guidelines you have to stay within
the brand what is the brand's
personality how do we want to talk to
our audience and what platform are we
using to talk to our audience how do you
promote your content once it's live well
that's always a good question hey you
doing the the work the putting in the
hard work to create this you know it
could be a video and videos take a long
time it could be an infographic an ebook
okay so send it out via email okay if
you have an email list send it out and
let people know this content's there put
a link in the email or or even a piece
or snippet or preview of the content in
the email so you're using the email to
broadcast and encourage people to you
know if it's an ebook get the rest of
the ebook okay you can certainly
leverage social media to engage with
your community that's the best you know
just as good as email get out there and
let people know hey i got i got my book
published come and download it you know
you can give a discount to the first 100
people that download it okay you can
always promote your content via ads so
whether that be google or facebook you
always have an opportunity to meet more
prominent by advertising the content
that you have to offer so you can always
reach out on social media again
targeting interesting people directly so
you can always interact with people on
social or you can write for others
attract people from the web to important
pages of your website by guest posting
so you can always go on to a popular
blog post and write something and you
know link it up or or have it be
relevant to the content you've written
so next question how can you determine
how well your content is doing okay very
important again you've done all the work
you put the content calendar together
you got the content ready to go it's
published you're promoting it social
email guest blogging but you want to
determine how it's doing well depends on
the channel really is what it comes down
to so if it's organic search you want to
be able to see if it's ranking for the
keywords you optimize that content for
if it's social you want to be able to
see if you have engagement shares
comments etc of course you can always
look at analytics and see how much
traffic that blog post is getting or
that page with the white paper is
getting okay so you can always look at
your analytics and look at the traffic
okay and again you can always look to
see if there are conversions in the form
of an inquiry or lead or sale so at the
end of the day you want to align the
content with the channel and you want to
align the kpi with the content and
channel okay so if it's social you're
not likely going to get conversions
unless you're doing paid ads if you're
posting organically on social then
you're probably going to get some
engagement so you have to align the
right metric with the right channel what
are the steps involved in the content
marketing process okay so you really
need to decide what goal you want to
achieve with the content marketing
campaign so that goes back to what i was
just saying a minute ago if you have
content you post it on social then
what's the goal what are you trying to
achieve well you're probably going to
get engagement and likes you need to
define buyer personas to determine the
audience best suited for your content
okay so you're always writing for an
audience and you're going to market that
content for that audience so you always
got to keep that in mind okay run
content audience audits to determine the
best type of content that can be used in
other words how did it perform what kind
of engagement did you get with the
infographic or did that video really
really perform well or do we want to use
you know a blog post next time around or
an image next time around so continuing
on here you want to choose an
appropriate content management system
okay so how are we managing all this
content okay is it wordpress or is it
another platform okay you could start
brainstorming for ideas for new content
so again that goes back to the content
calendar you leverage your content
counter to always create ideas for new
content okay then you want to settle on
a particular type of content that you
want to create okay so once you come up
and you're managing your content you you
come up with some ideas then you
obviously want to
choose the format and then of course you
want to publish and manage your content
after it's all said and done so these
are the steps involved again just
quickly decide on the goal the kpi
deciding your audience look at what's
worked and not worked in the past get
your content set up in the platform okay
or get the platform ready to go i should
say okay generate ideas with that
content counter i ideally go to the
content calendar for the ideas choose
that type and then publish and manage
and when i say manage i mean again going
back to analytics or going back to the
kpi that you align with that content to
see if it's performing or not okay so
next question here how do you target the
right audience for your content it's a
very good question you're not writing
content for everyone let's be honest
here so you have to collect demographics
of your target audience based on who's
coming to your website based on who
subscribed to your emails based on who's
following you on social media so in
other words you have people interacting
with you okay in different channels and
you need to understand who these people
are so if they fit a certain age range
your generation are they skewed more
female to male education level what's
their affinity or interest okay do they
have a certain income so you need to
really break down your audience here and
you could do that in analytics you could
do that on social you can do that just
by looking at your email list okay the
all those will paint a picture as to who
your audience is okay so good luck to
you whether you're at interviewing for
content marketing social email
pay-per-click seo
you're gonna have a plethora of
questions being asked to you hopefully
these questions are well suited for your
interview if you guys were asked any
questions that weren't brought up in
this video then feel free to comment
below i'd love to see what other
questions are being asked in digital
marketing interviews of course if you
have any questions feel free to visit us
at simplylearn.com i want to thank you
for hanging in there and good luck and
we'll see on the next video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here